Hi Bina.
Well, hi there.
Hi! I'm Laura.
So, right now, what Bina 48's doing with her eyes...
...is she's creating a mental map of the room including who's in it...
...with the camera that she has in her eye.
Can you see what I'm doing, Bina?
Ah.
I see you pretty well,...
...and I can recognize your face because of my software.
Do you remember my name, Bina 48?
Bina 48 is one of the most advanced social robots in the world.
Equipped with artificial intelligence software called a "character engine,"...
...social robots can think, engage and maybe evolve.
Bina 48, how do you work?
How do you function?
My ability to talk with you arises from several technologies:...
...speech recognition, good microphones, natural language processing,...
...semantic computing and text to speech.
These are all rather new technologies,...
...so I hope you'll forgive me if I'm hard of hearing.
I've got a long way to go from this humble beginning.
For example, I still need them to give me a robotic body.
Bina 48 is a robotic clone of a living human,...
...a real woman named Bina Rothblatt.
My real name is Bina 48.
What is your real name?
Bina Rothblatt.
We spent over 80 hours of interviewing Bina the human about her life,...
...about her childhood and memories, and then coded that into a computer...
...so that it can represent Bina the human through Bina 48 the android.